what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder it's me warren and
i just watched the first few episodes of
moon night marvel studios sent me them
early and i was pretty dang impressed
now you may notice i'm in a different
setup right now i'm traveling a little
bit helping my brother move across the
country so blank space right now but
i'll be back next week no big deal i
just want to let you guys know my
initial thoughts on moon night because
it's very very different
very different than really anything
we've seen in the mcu in a really good
way now this isn't like an official
review but here are my initial thoughts
about
moon night one i i really actually loved
the show um
i think moon knight is going to become a
favorite character of a lot of people
but i still do think there are going to
be some people that are like uh we i
kind of prefer loki or maybe i prefer
one division or whatever it may be
but it is a really really fantastic show
i i genuinely loved watching it now it
when i say it's weird
i mean that in a really good way
like it's it's good
weird and it very much has kind of like
creepy horror vibes to it um which i
think a lot of people are really really
going to enjoy
a lot of people have said before
that it doesn't feel too connected to
marvel and that's kind of true with the
exception of maybe
the
opening screen marvel studios logo
you really don't really know but i kind
of like that because they're kind of
doing it one off now i haven't watched
all of the episodes i've just watched
the first three they sent me four but
since i've been gone i haven't had time
to watch the fourth one yet but the
first three are
fantastic
the first one is good it kind of sets
everything up and then the second one
you really start to get into things and
it's just
visually really cool
but i love the story that's going on so
far and if you like midnight in the
comics you're really gonna like this
story as well it's really cool it's
really well put together um the fights
that we've seen so far really good it's
funny it is actually funny and i i gotta
give like all the praise to oscar isaac
because he does a really really good job
a really good job especially a stephen
grant he does a really good job as mark
spector but a steven grant
and to be able to go back and forth like
between the characters because as
everybody knows from just basic moon
night knowledge and what the trailer's
shown us so far he's kind of got
multiple personalities right he's
got a little bit of multiple
personalities going on so there are a
few different characters that we're
going to see throughout the entire
series um but the first few episodes
kind of focus on mark and steven and
oscar isaac does a fantastic job the
whole cast is creepy then hogs freaking
fantastic
really like kind of like a cult leader
vibe and you really get that like you've
seen that part in the trailer but you
like really really really get that cult
leader vibe from him he does a really
good job of playing that part so overall
i really enjoyed it i wish i could do a
full review right now to tell you all
how like i really feel but initial
reactions are for me are very very
positive um definitely one of the best
marvel mcu shows out there it's gonna
definitely be in like
probably my time we gotta see how it
ends right because an ending can ruin
everything but probably like a top two
top three mcu film i love loki i don't
know if it's going to be able to outdo
loki but we'll see
like i said i uh i've only seen the
first three episodes so we'll see where
it takes us but overall i think
everybody should be really excited for
moon night i think everybody's gonna
going to like how different it is
because it is pretty different i
i enjoy it being so different but it it
still kind of keeps that like the mcu
tone
with the
like the the comedic humor to it like
there are some farts i've laughed out
loud like quite quite a handful of times
while watching this but it also is
pretty
it is dark like people are saying but
not like you're like like a bad bad
taste kind of way like it's it's it's
executed perfectly i think and uh you
know no spoilers right obviously so but
seeing some of this stuff i'm like
that's cool they did that really well so
overall moon knight uh i'm excited to
watch the rest of the episodes i think
a lot of people are going to really
really really like the show and i think
a lot of people are going to have a new
favorite character after this um
and it's just overall really cool show
it's a lot of fun and i'm really excited
to see how it ends and let me know how
excited you guys are to finally watch it
in a couple weeks when it comes out in
the comments down below and don't forget
to subscribe for more moon night videos
don't forget to like the video and of
course for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof